[Rires]
travail épuisant
travail forcé
stress
[Musique]
accident du travail
punitions corporelles
propriétaire
voilà des mots que nous connaissons tous
êtes vous certain que le monde dans
lequel vous vivez à aboli l esclavage
depuis des siècles
[Musique]
voici mohamed il a 23 ans il vit au
bangladesh dans un endroit appelé nos à
cali
je suis l'aînée de la famille
le seul à pouvoir aider mon père
j'ai commencé à travailler à la
briqueterie pour que ma famille puisse
mieux vivre
il n'y a pas longtemps mohamed a eu ses
examens d'entrée à l'université
mais il n'a jamais pu commencer ses
études
[Musique]
le père de mohamed noro la mine
travailler à la briqueterie mais a eu un
accident
les riches familles hindoues ondées
serpent venimeux qui peuvent atteindre
quelques mètres de long et vivent dans
leur maison
on m'avait dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
serpents dans les pièces où ils stocker
l'acide
ils m'ont dit d'aller chercher de
la bouteille a explosé dans mes mains et
j'ai été brûlés
ils ont appelé une ambulance et m'ont
emmené à l'hôpital
tout a fondu à l'intérieur de mon corps
[Musique]
mohamed du travail et à la briqueterie à
la place de son père sa famille avait
besoin d'argent
au cours de la dernière décennie le
bangladesh a connu un boom de la
construction il est nécessaire de loger
une population d'environ 160 millions
d'habitants dont les revenus sont
faibles il ya donc beaucoup d' usine qui
fabrique des briques à bas coûts
personne ne connaît exactement leur
nombre mais elle pourrait être de huit à
dix mille dont près de 20 pour cent sont
illégales mais même les usines
respectant la loi offre des conditions
de travail qui sont loin d'être
confortable au sur
elles n'embauchent pas seulement des
hommes mais aussi des femmes et des
enfants
ce sont surtout des hommes qui nous ont
permis de filmer mais quelques enfants
aussi réussi à passer quelques fois
devant la caméra
[Musique]
les familles entières viennent
travailler ici
les bric ne peuvent être fabriqués
pendant la saison des pluies la période
humide inondent les fours ont dit que
cette briqueterie offre de bonnes
conditions de travail
les ouvriers évoque de bonnes conditions
de vie et trois repas par jour
mais aucun d'entre eux n'a dit vraiment
cela le propriétaire a interdit à tous
ses employés de donner des interviews
sous peine de licenciement
[Musique]
le processus de fabrication est simple
d'abord l'argile est extraite d'une
carrière et apporté à la briqueterie
ensuite elle est mélangée avec de l'eau
pour obtenir la bonne consistance
l'argile humide est ensuite coulé dans
des moules en bois le processus de
fabrication est principalement effectué
à la main certains outils mécaniques
sont utilisés à certaines étapes mais
uniquement lorsqu'il faut augmenter les
volumes de production
si on comparait une briqueterie du
milieu du 19e siècle à celle ci elle
serait quasi identique
l'expérience de mohamed al usine a mal
démarré son équipe a dû faire des heures
supplémentaires mais le directeur n'a
pas voulu les payer mohamed est alors
allé se plaindre auprès du propriétaire
j'ai dit la vérité mais à cause de cela
ils ont commencé à me frapper avec un
bâton
je les ai supplié d'arrêter
je leur demandais pardon
à baudre aubenas mais le propriétaire a
continué à me battre
jusqu'à ce que le bâton se casse
puis il a pris un autre bâton et a
continué à me battre il voulait me
mettre dans un four
le four dont parle mohamed est l'endroit
où les ouvriers mettre les briques une
fois sèche pour les faire cuire pendant
24 heures
si ses collègues n'étaient pas venus à
son secours il ne serait resté de
mohamed que cendres et poussières
je suis déjà un esclave
il faudrait être normalement au début
mai leurs attitudes changent du jour au
lendemain
finalement on vous traite pire qu'un
esclave
je ne pense pas qu'il y à un endroit au
monde où on parle aux travailleurs comme
ici il nous traite comme des chiens
ils ont plus de considération pour les
chiens que pour nous
g il vous plaît pour une certaine
quantité de travail
mais nous en faisons beaucoup plus
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
ils vous tapez dessus
ne vous donne pas à manger ne vous paie
pas
nous sommes obligés de faire tout ce
qu'ils demandent
sinon nous ne ferons que souffrir
[Musique]
les propriétaires de briqueteries se
plaignent souvent qu'un quart des brics
se fissure après avoir été passé au four
il estime normal de sous payer les
ouvriers à cause de ses pertes
mais les demies écart de brique se
vendent encore mieux que les briques
entière tout est utile quand il s'agit
de logements bon marché
mohamed a consulté un médecin pour ses
blessures et payer le traitement avec
son avance il est ensuite retournée
travailler à la briqueterie pour le
reste de la saison
[Musique]
les gens vont travailler là bas parce
qu'ils ne sont pas instruits ils n'ont
pas d'éducation
[Musique]
les propriétaires ne vois aucune
différence entre les animaux et les gens
sans éducation
cet homme s'appelle aussi mohamed
c'est un autre ouvrier de briqueteries
saisonniers il a 23 ans et il vient du
village sonar dit guy
oui nous risquons nos vies mais personne
ne se soucie de nous
ne faisons que travailler et travailler
et il nous fait mal
notre travail ne vaut rien
moi m n'exagère pas lorsqu'il dit qu'ils
risquent leur vie
vous voyez cette poussière elle est à
l'origine de graves maladies pulmonaires
et respiratoires chez beaucoup de
travailleurs
[Musique]
ils pensent peut-être que nous sommes
leurs esclaves mais nous ne sommes que
les esclaves dallas
et de personne d'autre
[Musique]
les travailleurs reçoivent environ 800 $
pour six mois de travail cet argent est
généralement payés en avance on leur
promet dé paiement d'heures
supplémentaires en plus qui n'arrive
généralement jamais
entre le propriétaire et les ouvriers il
y à un intermédiaire
c'est lui qui supervise les ouvriers et
leur donne leur paye c'est le
contremaître et c'est aussi lui qui
infligent les coûts au nom du
propriétaire
[Musique]
c'est un pays violent
ici tout n'est que souffrance
il se trouve que le père de mohamed
était contremaître
il ya des conflits permanents avec le
propriétaire ou les ouvriers
et dans chaque conflit c'est toujours le
contremaître qu'on blâme
les ouvriers sont souvent enfermés dans
leurs baraquements de sorte qu'il ne
puisse pas partir après avoir reçu leur
avance
ce qui arrive parfois
[Musique]
ouahmed été gardées sous clé comme un
hôte à ajoie prisonniers
certains ouvriers ont tout de même
réussi à appeler la police
[Musique]
la police est arrivée à midi
nous étions heureux
nous pensions que tout était fini
nous ne pouvions même pas bouger
tellement nous avions mal
ils ont noté les noms et les adresses de
chacun
tout d'un coup ils ont reçu un appel
de suite après les policiers se sont
calmés
ils ont très probablement reçu un appel
d'un supérieur qui leur a dit de partir
dès que les policiers sont partis ils
ont continué de nous battre
que pouvons nous faire
ils nous battent et nous tenons le coup
[Musique]
mohammed devant un enterrement un
villageois est mort
comme tout le monde ici il travaillait
également à la briqueterie
[Applaudissements]
tous ses revenus ont été dépensés pour
que sa famille puisse vivre dans ce
village
la maison qui leur a laissé n'est même
pas construite en brique ou en fragments
de briques
[Musique]
on fabrique on des briques
les briques sont transmises d'un ouvrier
à un autre jusqu'à ce qu'elle atteigne
la maison d'un riche
se construisent des maisons à plusieurs
étages il mène la belle vie tandis que
nous vivons dans des maisons qui n'ont
même pas de toi
il n'y a pas de fin heureuse à ces
histoires personne ne défend les
travailleurs et leurs droits
et le propriétaire de la briqueterie
n'encourt aucune sanction c'est trop
courant mais c'est la réalité